[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein schnelles Pastarezept.
Ich weiß, Murat wird nicht so ganz glücklich darüber sein,
denn ich mache ein Pastarezept mit Kürbis.
Aber ich habe euch gefragt
per Instagram und habe gesagt:
"Wollt ihr Rezepte mit Kürbis? Ja oder Nein?"
Und viele haben gesagt: Ja.
Und deswegen gibt es heute ein Kürbisrezept
mit Vollkornnudeln.
Und ich mache dazu noch Shrimps.
Also Tigergarnelen habe ich jetzt hier,
Tiger-Garnelen, Black-Tiger-Garnelen.
Und das ist auch tatsächlich
eine Premiere auf meinem Kanal, denn
ich habe es eigentlich nicht so ganz mit Meeresfrüchten.
Allerdings fand ich sie hier drin richtig lecker.
Denn wir haben das Gericht schon mal
in Österreich gegessen
bei einem guten Freund,
dessen Frau das für uns gekocht hat.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie sie es gemacht hat,
aber ich denke so, wie ich es jetzt gleich machen werde
– hoffe ich.
Ich hoffe, es wird mir genauso gut gelingen
wie bei euch.
Und ihr könnt das Ganze natürlich
auch gerne ohne Garnelen zubereiten.
Dann ist es sogar vegan und vegetarisch sowieso.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt mal,
was ich an Zutaten dafür brauche.
Ich habe jetzt hier auch schon Salat.
Da habe ich Blutampfer, Sauerampfer,
ein bisschen Knoblauch
– nee, Knobloch und Schnittlauch aus dem Garten
und Tomaten.
Den gibt es dann gleich einfach noch dazu.
Hier habe ich schon die Tiger-Garnelen.
Die sind aus dem Tiefkühlfach.
Und die habe ich jetzt bereits geschält.
Entdarmt sind sie nämlich schon.
Dann brauche ich Zwiebeln und Knoblauchzehen.
Hier habe ich etwas Olivenöl,
einen Hokkaido-Kürbis,
Salbei aus dem Garten,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Hier habe ich noch Vollkornpasta,
– ich nehme jetzt hier Spaghetti –
Kürbiskerne
und noch getrocknete Tomaten.
Die sind in Öl gelegt.
Die getrockneten Tomaten,
die habe ich übrigens auch selber gemacht.
Also das waren unsere Cocktailtomaten.
Die habe ich gedörrt und dann mit Knoblauch
und Kräutern einfach in Öl eingelegt.
Und jetzt fange ich direkt mal an
mit dem Kürbis zuerst einmal.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Hokkaido.
Das ist eigentlich auch so der gängigste Kürbis,
muss man dazu sagen.
Und bei dem ist der Vorteil,
dass ihr ihn nicht schälen müsst.
Ich halbiere den jetzt.
Da müsst ihr nur immer aufpassen,
dass ihr nicht abrutscht mit dem Messer.
So. Kurz den Boden weg
und das da oben weg.
Die Kerne könnt ihr tatsächlich aufheben und essen.
Die kann man nämlich schön auswaschen
und dann rösten.
Und dann habt ihr Kürbiskerne.
Und ich schneide den jetzt hier einfach schön in Spalten.
Ihr könnt den aber auch fein würfeln, wenn ihr möchtet.
Ich finde jetzt nur Spalten irgendwie schöner auf dem Teller.
Das ist echt jetzt nur eine optische Entscheidung.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier schon mal das Olivenöl erhitzen.
Auf mittelhoher Stufe ungefähr.
Ich mache das jetzt hier in einem großen Bräter,
weil ich, wie gesagt, heute eine große Portion habe,
weil wir eben Besuch haben.
Aber ihr könnt auch eine kleine Pfanne nehmen
oder einen kleinen Gusseisentopf.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Nudelwasser auch schon mal bereithalten.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich jetzt hier
die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel dazu geben.
Auch schön mit anbraten.
Ich mache jetzt auch bewusst den Fisch zum Schluss, denn
so kann ich noch eine vegane Portion
für den Dennis mit rausnehmen,
so ohne Fisch.
Jetzt einfach schön anbraten,
bis die Zwiebeln ein bisschen glasig sind,
bis der Kürbis so ein bisschen karamellisiert ist.
Und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Denn ich habe gerade nichts zu tun.
Ich mache solang mein Salatdressing.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich hier auch die Salbeiblätter dazu.
Die großen könnt ihr gern so ein bisschen halbieren.
Ruhig auch viel Salbei dazu geben.
Und dann auch schon mal mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen,
damit der Kürbis schon mal
einen schönen Geschmack bekommt.
Muskat dazu reiben.
[Musik]
Kurz den Salbei noch mit anbraten lassen.
Und ich gebe auch direkt noch
die Tomaten dazu, die getrockneten.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich hier ganz kurz alles raus.
Normalerweise, wenn es jetzt eine kleine Portion wäre,
hätte ich einfach alles auf die Seite geschoben,
so,
und hier die Shrimps angebraten,
dann die Nudeln dazu.
Aber ich habe ja jetzt schon einige Shrimps.
Deswegen nehme ich das kurz raus, dass ich Platz habe.
Aber, wie gesagt, müsst ihr nicht,
wenn ihr eine kleine Portion kocht.
Dann noch mal ein bisschen Olivenöl.
Und schön die Shrimps jetzt anbraten.
Ich schalte jetzt den Herd wieder ein bisschen höher.
[Musik]
Die Nudeln habe ich gerade abgegossen.
Hier eine vegane Portion
für Dennis.
Und hier habe ich jetzt auch...
Was?
>> SARAH: Ich dachte,
>> SALLY: Komm.
>> SARAH: du hast nur Nudeln für Dennis.
>> SALLY: Nein,
da ist schon Kürbis unten drin
>> SARAH: Ach so.
>> SALLY: ohne Garnelen.
Guck mal, wie schön das aussieht.
>> SARAH: Das sieht sehr gesund und lecker aus.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und da kommen jetzt die Vollkornnudeln dazu, Sarah.
Wow!
Oh!
Wie will ich das jetzt verrühren, he?
>> SARAH: Ich schaue zu und staune.
>> SALLY: Wie will die Sally das jetzt verrühren?
>> SARAH: Ich bin gespannt.
>> SALLY: Warte mal.
Wow!
Wisst ihr, bei Nudeln,
ich bin da echt so,
ich übertreibe es dann immer gleich.
Wenn ich so weiß, es kommen sechs Personen,
mache ich immer gleich so ein Kilo.
Dabei ist ja eine Portion
– also 500 Gramm sind doch für...
>> SARAH: Oh, bei Nudeln weiß ich nicht.
Da kenne ich keine Mengenangaben.
>> SALLY: Ja, warte. Ich mache noch ein paar raus.
>> SARAH: Ich habe auch das Talent,
mich an Nudeln immer zu überessen.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> SARAH: Ich höre nicht auf.
Ich höre bei Nudeln einfach nicht auf zu essen.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde...
>> SARAH: Ich habe auch extra die Schürze angezogen.
Weil bei Nudeln mache ich mich auch immer dreckig.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> SARAH: Beim Nudelnessen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also eigentlich war das Rezept recht einfach.
Das Schwierigste ist jetzt nur, diese Riesenmenge
umzurühren.
>> SARAH: Die in den Griff zu bekommen.
>> SALLY: Okay. Aber ich gebe dir einfach schon mal
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: so eine Portion
und dann noch so vom
Gemüse.
>> SARAH: Garnelen?
>> SALLY: Garnelen.
Premiere.
>> SARAH: Shrimps oder Garnelen?
>> SALLY: Man kann beides sagen.
>> SARAH: Ja?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Das weiß ich nie.
>> SALLY: Ich habe das schon mal gegoogelt
und irgendwie sagt man...
>> SARAH: Ich dachte immer, Shrimps wären die Größeren
– nee, andersrum,
Shrimps wären die Kleineren.
>> SALLY: Dachte ich auch.
Nee, Krabben sind doch die Kleinen.
Krabben sind die ganz Kleinen, diese Nordseekrabben.
>> SARAH: Sehen die auch so aus in Klein?
>> SALLY: Nee, die sind ganz klein.
Die sind so richtig klein,
so mini, mini.
>> SARAH: Okay. Aber man kann
dazu Shrimps und Garnelen sagen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Jetzt noch ein bisschen Salz,
Pfeffer
und Kürbiskerne.
>> SARAH: Essen wir wieder zusammen?
>> SALLY: Ja, komm.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Hier.
>> SARAH: Ich finde es schwierig,
wenn du das da nach oben hältst.
>> SALLY: Ich muss echt sagen, Vollkornnudeln finde ich gut.
>> SARAH: Ja.
Ich habe dir einen Löffel hingelegt.
Ach so, du kannst...
>> SALLY: Italiener machen das aber so am Tellerrand.
>> SARAH: Ach so, du bist Italienerin.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wusstest du das nicht?
>> SARAH: Nee, bis jetzt nicht.
>> SALLY: Und dann schlürft man den Rest einfach.
>> SARAH: Hey, das ist schwierig.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hätte mehr Kürbis sein dürfen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder...
>> SARAH: Ist das ein ganzer?
>> SALLY: Oder weniger Nudeln.
>> SARAH: Oder das.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Auch mit dem Salbei.
Woah, ist eine gute Kombi.
>> SALLY: Echt gut.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Schmeckt direkt so, als würde man Tee trinken.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Was für ein Tee?
>> SARAH: Ein Kürbistee mit Salbei.
Also ich finde tatsächlich,
für die Kürbismenge hätte auch
eine Packung Nudeln gereicht.
Dann hat man richtig so ein gutes Verhältnis zwischen.
>> SARAH: Finde ich auch.
>> SALLY: So schreibe ich es euch auch im Blog auf.
Aber jetzt habe ich hier eine Riesenmenge.
Ich brate einfach noch ein bisschen Kürbis dazu an mit Salbei,
lege das hier noch mit rein.
Und dann habe ich was für meine Gäste.
Und ihr könnt das Rezept gerne nachmachen.
Schreibt mir mal, ob ihr generell
auch Fan von Meeresfrüchten seid oder nicht.
Also bei mir Garnelen gehen mittlerweile,
alles andere tatsächlich nicht.
Das mag ich nicht so.
So Muscheln und alles kann ich nicht.
>> SARAH: Aber du hast Oktopus gegessen.
>> SALLY: Ich habe es probiert.
>> SARAH: Und war gar nicht schlecht.
>> SALLY: Und es war lecker.
>> SARAH: Ich kann es nur nicht,
wenn man die Tentakel sieht.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Dann...
>> SALLY: Da hat man es dann nicht so gesehen.
Das war dann okay.
Es war echt lecker, aber, wie gesagt, so zubereiten,
da bin ich selber noch so ein bisschen...
Aber dieses Kürbisrezept ist richtig lecker.
Ihr könnt es vegan machen oder auch mit Meeresfrüchten,
so, wie ihr gerne möchtet.
Und das Rezept findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de.
O mein Gott! Ich finde, das sieht so schön aus hier!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: So richtig herbstlich.
>> SARAH: So schön herbstlich.
>> SALLY: Mach so.
Sisters by heart.
>> SARAH: Ich lasse sogar mein Essen für dich liegen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Tschüss.
Mehr kann man nicht sagen.
Es war so schön!
>> SARAH: Ein Traum!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ich lass für dich das Licht an,
obwohl's mir zu hell ist!
Ich höre mir
>> SALLY & SARAH: Bands an, die ich nicht mag!
>> SALLY: Ich bin für dich leise, wenn du zu laut...
[Musik]